- I looked at it as I have an ATM
between my legs and I
just, I'm just using it.
All I got to do is put
my card in and that's it.
And put the pin number and boom
money just comes right out.
It was like, pussy is just, this treasure
that women are born with and
I would knew how to use it.
- All right.
Tiye, Tiye, where are you from originally?
Where did you grow up?
- I grew up in Durham, North
Carolina, up until I was 12.
And then I moved to
Washington state with my dad
and till I was 16.
- And how was your childhood?
- My childhood was very dysfunctional.
It was very dysfunctional.
I remember from a very early age,
I'd probably say three or four years old.
My dad would take me with him to go
and cheat on my mom.
And I remember, you, for,
and he used to do this for.
For me, it felt like a
long time 'cause I remember
going to school and my dad, I mean,
I remember going to school
and going to my teachers
and telling them, oh, I have
eighteen brothers and sisters.
And they were like, they
thought that was wild, you know.
And like somehow my, I don't
know how my parents found out
but somehow they found out.
And I remember my mom just like,
just being like, why
are you lying to them?
You don't have eighteen
brothers and sisters.
And she just kind of
left it alone, you know.
My family thought it was funny
but really, they didn't know that.
It was because my dad was taking me
to go see all these women.
And I would just sleep in the living room
while he would just go and have an affair.
And seeing that was wild.
It was, and my dad did it
so much that in kindergarten
I remember seeing the guy
that had a crush on me
and now, somehow, I'm at his house
and my dad is hanging out with his mom
and it was just weird.
It was just like, wow, like,
I'm really seeing all these women.
And like, they all had kids and like,
but the dad was never around.
It was, it was different.
And then on top of that,
my dad was very abusive.
He was very mind fucking.
I remember seeing him drag my mother
with my baby sister in her hands.
And he dragged her from the steps outside
and just dragged her outside
and was beating on her.
And she was just crying and
I just couldn't remember why.
I didn't know.
I didn't understand why he
did what he did, you know,
and not understanding why
my dad has so much anger.
And like my dad would just
beat us for, for no reason.
It was, it was dramatic.
My dad just had really bad,
really bad anger issues.
And I just remember wanting
to get away from him so bad.
And I couldn't, you know, even
like he would always threaten
he would like, do you
want me to seeing back
to North Carolina to
go live with your mom?
And I'm like, no, cause like,
what am I going to do there?
You know?
But, and then I don't
know, it was just weird.
He was just, he was so controlling
and so mind fucking to
the point where like,
even when we moved to Washington state,
I didn't even have a choice.
Like he asked me, I remember,
it was on a Wednesday, right,
And he asked me, he was like, so you know,
you know me and your mom were
getting a divorce and do you,
do you want to come move to
Washington state with me?
I was like, no, I'm going to stay here.
And then he was like, well,
too bad, we already
bought the plane ticket
and I'm not about to wait case money.
So we're going to, you're going
to move to Washington state.
And I'm like, okay.
And then Friday, I was literally
in a whole new household.
I was in, I was the only black girl
in my whole entire fucking school.
That was weird.
And then, and then like,
I'm moving in with these,
with, I wouldn't, I don't
want to call them these,
but moving in with my step sisters
and everything was just different.
Then I get off the plane and
see my dad kiss another woman.
It was just so, everything
was so different.
Everything was just like
this big, like culture shock
for no fucking reason.
Like it was just, it was too much.
And having to play family
and she didn't even like us.
She didn't want us to be there.
She only kept us there
'cause my dad wanted us there
and it's like, I want my mom.
And I couldn't have my mom.
And I just, I remember,
I wanted her so bad.
No. thank you, thank you.
I just remember that I
wanted my mom so bad.
I just wanted her so bad
and I couldn't have her
because she was so far,
I got him all the way Washington state
and she all the way North Carolina
and I couldn't do anything about that.
But, we had to stay and
that had to deal with
what we had to deal with.
And it felt like it was
like a Cinderella story.
You know, where you have
like your, they weren't evil,
they didn't know any better, you know.
I don't blame them, they
didn't know any better,
but, they always got the
better end of the stick
than all of us.
So it was just, it was just weird,
like watching my dad like,
catered to someone else's
kids than us, you know.
And like, he always treated them so nice.
And it would always just be like,
why can't you be more like them?
And it's like, I'm your kid.
Why can't, you know,
like, why can't you just
love me for who I am?
You know?
And it was just, it was tough.
It was tough.
Like, I'm in an abusive relationship
and I'm 16 years old in
an abusive relationship
and he's super abusive.
And then I'm, I, I'm
four years down the line,
we're still together.
and we had a kid together last year.
I decided, I'm like,
I don't want to be in
this relationship anymore.
Like, he gives me STD and I got it.
I'm like, I got to go, you know,
he's sexually abusive, mentally
abusive, emotional abuses,
anything you can think of that's abusive.
That motherfucker was it.
He was abusive.
And so I was like, I gotta
go, I gotta get out of here.
So then I get out of there, but like,
like two months down
the line, I lose my job.
So I'm jobless and I do not
have a place to call my own.
And so I'm like, sleeping on a
couch at my friend's grandma.
Well, not a couch, there's bed
but I'm sleeping in her home
and I need some cash.
My car broke down
and like, I need money to fix it.
So then, I go and I
meet with Ronnie, right.
And found him on Backpage.
Never heard of Backpage before.
My best friend showed me that
so I meet up with Ronnie.
And he has all these liquor
bottles in his cabinet.
Cause this is, he does
the, this, he says that
I was supposed to do like
a massage or whatever.
And I was like, cool.
Like, he's like, yeah.
They're like these older men,
they love it when young women come
and they give them a massage,
and I was like awesome.
Like, this is cool.
I'm like, that's all I
got to do is a massage.
I was like, great.
You know, and he was like,
I'll make all this money
but he has all these liquor
in his, in his cabinet.
And he's just like, you know, I haven't,
if you can have as many
drinks as you want,
I'll make as many drinks as you want.
I have feminine products if you need them,
if you need to douche,
if you need panty liners,
if you need condoms or anything.
I'm like condoms?
And then he was like, yeah, no, no, no,
like, you know, like for yourself.
I'm like, oh, oh, okay.
And then, I go and I
haven't make me a drink.
And he's like, yeah, this is
going to really keep you calm.
It's going to keep you calm.
And this is all within the
first day of meeting him.
And then he's like, but I also have Xanax
and mind you, this guy is a counselor.
He works for, he works with
mental health patients.
He's a fucking counselor,
he's sick, but he has Xanax.
And he's like, do you want some?
I was like, I've never had Xanax before.
What is that?
And he's like, Oh, it'll
just keep you calm.
He was like, you'll
just feel super relaxed.
I was like, okay.
So he's like, usually people football it,
just like we take the whole
thing, but I'm like, he's like,
but since you're new,
just take a third of it.
I'm like, all right.
So then, I take a third
of it and I'm shrinking
and I still don't feel it,
so I took another part of the third.
Well, the second part of it,
cause it's cut up into three.
And so I take the second part
and then like, I'm really
feeling, feeling really groovy.
And then the first client
comes over and I do my thing.
And at this point, that's when like,
Ronnie is like telling me,
like, you know, you, you gotta like,
provide sexual services.
And he tells me this one
when I'm high, so like,
I don't give a fuck.
And then how am I cool?
Fuck it, whatever, you know.
And then, then he's
telling me all the prices
and the upgrades and the client comes over
and I do my thing or whatever.
And then the second guy comes,
and Ronnie can see it cause
he has his X-box camera on
and he's connected to his TV in his room.
And the guy, and I'm laying
down and the guy's like,
I want to give you a massage.
So he gives me a massage
and I'm blacked out at
this point, now I'm gone.
I don't remember anything that happens.
Comes to find out,
Ronnie liked, wakes me up
and I just see him running
out his room with a gun.
And then, I guess apparently
the guy was trying to rape me
and take advantage of me and
I'm like, passed the fuck out.
And then Ronnie scares them off
and then that's shits
scares me the fuck off.
And I'm like, I don't want to
do this, like, this is not me.
I'm like, no, no, no.
But he was still mind fucking,
he would tell me like,
come on, make some money.
And I, and I went back
a couple of times and,
but then like, there
was one time where like,
my pH balance, you know, like
yeast infection came around
and that's when I was like, I
was like, I can't work today.
And then he was so pissed.
He was just like, no,
don't worry about the den,
don't fucking comeback.
And I was like, what?
He was like, yeah, no, you're
done. I'm done with you.
I'm like what? I'm like, I
need the money, you know.
So then I was like, whatever,
that's not going to work out.
So then my friend went back on Backpage,
and then she found the spa
and that's when everything changed.
And then, I met up with
Maddie and Victoria.
They were the first spa owners I ever met,
and they were so, so sweet.
They were so, so nice.
And I told them, I was like, look,
I don't want to have sex with any men.
I was like, if I have to
do that, then I, I'm out.
I don't want to do this.
And then she's like, if I
find out you're having sex
at my spa, I will fire you.
I was like, cool.
So here I am, I'm working
at a Jack Shack, right.
And I'm working at a Jack
Shack and it's weird.
It is weird, like the pricing
and everything is weird.
So like, they charge $60 for 30 minutes.
That's just to get in.
And then, it's an, it's $80 for an hour.
And then, then that's,
that money doesn't go to me
that goes to the owners.
And then, they tip you on top of that.
And, and then, you know, they,
they tip you however much
you want, you know, but,
but the spa worked out or
they were like weirdos.
They're like weirdo, weirdos.
Like there was this guy
I think his name was something like that.
But he liked to pluck my hair
and floss his teeth with it.
And then, yeah, weird.
And then he had a tiff foot fetish,
so I would sit up on
the bed like, oh, sorry.
I would sit up on the bed like this,
and then have my foot out,
and then he would drink water off of it.
And he would like praise
my foot, like he loved it.
And then like, I would, I would
like choke him with my foot,
like in his mouth, just
like, in there, just.
And he loved it.
And he, and he just,
and he, he was so happy.
And then this one guy came
in one time before and
but my best friend saw him
and he would shut the whole place down.
He dropped $1,500, right.
And he wanted you to fuck him in the ass,
and he wanted you to pee in his mouth,
and I think he wanted you
to take a shit on him.
But I do know he wants
you to fuck him in the ass
and pee in his mouth.
Yeah, and they pay for that.
It's so weird.
Men are so fucking weird.
But I didn't last that long at that spa.
It, was it Eos?.
Yeah, Eos spa in Charlotte.
It didn't last very
long. They got shut down.
And then I was like, well,
I gotta find somewhere else.
I was literally on my
way to work that day.
And well, I got a call, I was about to,
like I was like a couple
blocks down and I got a call.
They're like, don't
come in, don't come in.
The feds are here, the feds are here.
I was like, okay, fine.
All right, I won't go.
So then I'm like, what the
fuck I'm gonna do for work?
So then I go back on my
good old Backpage again
and I find a place called,
and that one's also run
by a female, as well.
And, but she's very good at what she does.
She's very mind controlling
and very mind fucking.
She's, she's mean, she's very, very mean.
She used to make us wear
heels 14 hours a day.
Mind you, we only worked
like three, four times out of the week,
but we were forced to
wear those heels 14 hours
out of the day.
And she told us, you
will get naked for $80.
It's so, you see, I guess
I had, I had a woman pimp.
Yeah. I had a woman pimp, yeah.
She was like, you will get naked for $80.
You will let them touch you for a $100,
and you will, and it all
comes with a hand job.
It doesn't matter, like
even if they tipped you $60
and it was topless, then you still have
to give them a hand job.
I was just like this, but mind you,
I come from an abusive father.
I come from an abusive ex-boyfriend.
I'm used to this shit,
I'm used to just turning off the switch
and just doing what people
told me to do, so I do it.
And then, then I stay with her for a while
but then she just gets really
mind fucking, I can't do it.
She was, she was too much
but I did make really
good money from it though.
But, but she also had worked clients too.
I had a guy, my last client there,
he, he paid me $140 just
to pee, piss in his mouth,
not to touch his dick,
just to pee in his mouth.
Just to pee in his mouth,
yeah, just to pee in his mouth.
Yeah. Weirdo.
And oh yeah, spit in his face and yeah.
And the spit in his face, but
to like, look at him like,
like spit in his face
and call him like names
but like looking at the
floor, it was so weird.
It was so complicated, but I'm so glad
that I got 140 just for
doing that, but yeah.
But then, I left her and then,
I also met, had met sugar
daddies there as well.
So I used to be like,
what'd you call it a
professional sugar baby.
And then I went to various
different other spas
that didn't really, they
weren't really my thing.
But then my best one I went to was,
that one I started doing
full-service. That one got crazy.
They, I mean, you could
charge from anywhere
from 800 to 900 to 600,
300 fridges, with just
fucking, you just, for pussies,
for some pussy, this was a pussy.
That's not even a song, like
a head like, just for pussy.
And men, men don't, I
mean, from my experience,
they don't last that long.
They last like, what five, ten minutes?
Not even like, and that's like,
I made half of somebody's check
that they would get it
two weeks in 30 minutes.
And I didn't even have to pop
it for that long, you know?
And, but then you also
have more weirdos there
and they had one guy pay me
$300 just to fart in his mouth.
Just to fart in his mouth.
And then, and then there was
one guy, he walk his fucking,
he wants you to sound like a pig,
he wants you to go,
(imitating pig sound)
That was so funny.
And then, and there's an,
obviously you got your peers.
I want you to pee on them,
that, that never changes,
you still pee on them.
They want you to pee on
them, which was funny.
And then, and then you had
some that wanted you to,
to finger them in their ass.
You obviously were glad
for that, I'm not, no.
And then, you have some
that, my favorite was John.
He paid money for nothing.
He didn't want you to touch his dick.
He didn't want you to do
nothing, but just spank him.
And he would give you $900.
Just right there, just right there.
And he was a regular and
he would, and he loved it
and he was come in like
all dressed up and,
and he was just, and he was
just speaks so nice and so soft.
And he would just, he was
just like, yeah, yeah.
I'm having such a great day, yeah.
And then he'd get in the room.
And then he puts his, he
wants you to have his panties
laid out and his bra
and his little stockings
that come up here that have
the little ruffles on them.
And then he wants you
to have his paddle out
and his little bunny butt plug.
And then sometimes we'll have his,
his dick chamber that you
have to put a lock on.
He wants that there too.
Sometimes, it just depends on
what he's into, yeah, that day.
And then, you spank them
for about 30 minutes
and sometimes he'll want two girls
and then he'll have two girls come in
and then sometimes three.
And then, the next thing you know,
you got the whole spa on there.
And then yeah, it was, he
was amazing, I loved him.
Sometimes he would come
in and only pay 300.
But most times he paid a lot of money,
he paid really, really good money.
But, to shed some light on it,
a lot of the girls in there
are not forced to be there.
We are there because
we want it to be there
or we want to be there.
For my friends that are still
there, they want to be there.
They're not sex trafficked.
They're not forced to be there.
They, that's their craft.
That's what they want to do.
But most girls that are in there
they don't realize that
they have a lot of trauma
and they realized that they,
that they're hurting still, you know.
Like me, like when I was in it,
I didn't realize that I
was so good at what I did
because I've been so sexually
abused and I had been so hurt
and raped so many times that I was able
to just click it off.
And when I went to work, I was Michelle.
When I went to work, I was Naomi.
When I went to work, I was Haley.
When I went to work, you
know, oh my gosh, so many,
Kendall, Gigi, so many different.
I was somebody else.
I was, when I went in
there I was no longer
what people knew me as Nicole.
I wasn't that, you know, I wasn't Tiye
as my family knows me, I wasn't that.
I was all of the above.
I was somebody else, you know.
And that's why it made
it easy for me to do it
but eventually it gets old.
Eventually you have to get
out of that, but it is,
it was one hell of a, one hell of a time.
- Did you save money?
- Did I save money?
Yes I did. That's how I
got here, cause I saved.
- So that was Charlotte, North Carolina?
- That was Charlotte, North Carolina.
Charlotte is a big hub,
for sex trafficking and for
like sex jobs and stuff so.
- And did, did doing
this for how many years?
Two years?
- Yeah. Two, three years, yeah.
- Did it change the way you see men?
- Yeah, a lot.
It changed the way I see married men
because 99% of the men
that came in were married.
And I apologize if I'm
messed up any marriages.
But I never looked at it that way.
I looked at it as you
put $300, you put 400,
whatever you put money on that table
and my pussy was okay
with it. It was over.
I looked at it as I have an
ATM between my legs and I just,
I'm just using it.
All I gotta do is put my
card in and that's it.
And put the pin number and boom
money just comes right out.
It was like, pussy is just,
this treasure that women are born with.
And I would knew how to use it,
but I only knew how to use it
because that's what they
would take away from me.
That's would men would do
to me, they would take that.
It would take my dignity
away from me, so yeah.
And you make a lot of money from it, so.
- So the downside, is it kind
of undermines your self-worth,
or your, your happiness?
- Sort of yeah.
And, and even like my boy, my ex-boyfriend
when I moved to Charlotte,
like I've met him through there
and we dated for two years.
And it fucked me up hard,
like trying to fall back in love again.
It fucked me up like,
cause it was just like,
he wasn't mind controlling,
he wasn't mind fucking,
he was a good guy.
He just loved prostitutes.
He just loved like, not girls
that would go into like
the spas or whatever.
I, I must've been different,
but he, I'd always catch him.
He was always talking to
prostitutes, like he'd always like,
call them and then like texting them.
And I'm like, dude, like, knock, knock,
you gotta escort right here.
You know, at home, like wake up.
I guess, I guess, I just
wasn't enough for him, I guess.
I don't know.
But that, that me fucked up, you know,
like that I'm messed up on, you know,
but I did have a good time.
I did enjoy myself.
I did.
I didn't let it hurt me.
I didn't let it affect me.
I did, I have something to show for it.
That's one thing I always
wanted to make sure
that I had something to show for it.
And I do.
I, I traveled as much as I could.
I, I, my daughter never had
to worry about any of that.
She, the way my daughter is right now
is because of how I, of,
of, how much I spoiled her.
The girl literally thinks she's a princess
and the only thing she's
missing is her fucking castle.
I swear.
She's so fortunate.
Until this day, she's still fortunate
because her mom set her up so well.
- So your life is good today?
- My life is still good today,
even though, we even though
like, with the whole,
with the whole eviction
moratorium, whatever.
We're still good, you know.
We're still, we're still
living okay, you know.
- How are you supporting yourself now?
- Now? Well, before
Golden Crown shut down,
it was Golden Crown,
but they just called me
back to go back to work, so.
That was such a weird transition.
- So where you working?
- At Golden Crown.
- Oh, restaurant.
- Yeah, yeah, the
restaurant, as a waitress.
- Got it.
- That was a weird transition too.
Trying to get away from that
I started out as a supervisor at CVS
and then I got tired of that.
And then I moved to Golden Crown
and then that's what I do now.
- You're walking away from sex workers.
- It's so hard cause
you make so much money,
like I remember like, my
second day working there
I made $1,600 in one day.
In one day, that is somebody's paycheck
that takes him like two weeks to get.
- And now at CVS or your
restaurant, you're making how much?
- Oh God, barely 300 in a weekend.
- Right?
- Maybe. That that's back when before
the pandemic, you know.
- That's a hard adjustment.
- It's a hard adjustment.
Yeah but, I knew what I
was getting myself into.
You know, I knew it. I knew
what I was getting myself into.
So I had to prepare myself for it.
What I was was for my desires.
It wasn't doing anything
for me, spiritually.
I was letting anybody just be inside of me
as long as they put the right
amount of money on that table,
it's like, I didn't give a, I
didn't give a fuck, you know.
But, cause at the end of
the day, the most, the less,
the last I ever walked
out with at a nice spa,
I mean like on a slow
day, I'd make like $600.
And that's probably from
seeing like two people
and not even having to have sex, still.
And the most, like on a regular basis
at most 1200, 900, you know,
a day I'm set, I'm set.
I can travel. Do whatever
the fuck I want to do.
You know?
But it's like, you gotta train your mind
to get out of a situation like that.
You know?
You gotta train your mind to think like,
I don't need these things.
These things aren't important.
And that was hard because going from,
Oh! I can just, I don't,
I can just buy that.
You know, even like switching from like,
I can't just go on Amazon anymore
and just like, go on a
shopping spree like that.
Like, I got to really just be like, ah,
I guess I'll save it for
later type shit, you know.
Like it's terrible,
it's a terrible mindset.
Like I'm young, I'm 20 years old,
making a fuck ton of money before I'm 21.
And then I'm 23, I already owned two cars.
Like, that are paid off, they're
not, I'm not leasing them.
I'm not, I don't owe money on them, no.
They are completely paid off in my name.
What 23 year old has that kind of shit?
Except you know.
- What, what, what would you
say to a young, you're 24 now?
- I'm 24 now.
- So what would you say to a young girl
whose considering doing
something like this?
Because times are tough
right now. Money is scarce.
- Don't do it, unless, unless
you have sexual trauma,
unless you have sexual
trauma, that was the only way
that it will allow you to
get through this because men,
men treat you like, you are,
like they just went through
a fast food drive-thru
and they're literally looking at you,
like you're on the menu
at McDonald's, literally.
Like a lot of times I had to
tell those men, I'm just like,
they're like, oh, can
you do it for this much?
I'm like, no, like you
can't even go to McDonald's
and ask them, oh, can I
have a Big Mac for $1?
No. If the price is what the price is.
Okay. You can't just like,
you can't just try to talk an employee
out of giving you a damn
Big Mac for like, for $2.
You can't, that's impossible, you know?
And so it's like, you got
to know how to be strong
and to put your foot down.
Now, I do know while working there,
it helped me be a strong woman.
A lot of people, you know,
and even my boyfriend today,
he still tries to say like, you know,
you working there made
you less of a woman.
No, it didn't.
It may have made me less of
a woman because of what I did
but even then it taught me
something that my fucking father
didn't teach me nor my, nor
my poor mother, you know.
They didn't teach me how to have a voice
and now I have a voice.
I stick up for myself.
I don't let anybody talk down to me.
I won't, I won't allow it.
And because I work there, I
learned to stick up for myself.
I learned to speak up
and I learned to not let
anybody talk down to me.
- Tiye, thank you so much
for telling your fascinating story.
- Thanks.
- Very interesting.
- Thanks for having
me. I do appreciate it.